hi I'm Hannah Hart and right now I'm
about to do an interview that I was not
prepared for in fact that pretty sure
I'm supposed to be shooting in the
limited time that I have to choose boo
Boop I'm at YouTube space la to
collaborate with one of my favorite
people Thanks monsters Godzilla today
what I'd like to do is have a really
personal interview with Godzilla and dig
deep into the issues about what makes
this monster behave the way he does or
she does this August I'm releasing my
first book my drunk kitchen a guide to
gut instincts that's the abbreviated
title it's a cookbook but also a parody
self-help book that really dives deep
into the issues that make us who we are
Godzilla said that it's his favorite
book of all time
a lot of people have been asking me
Grayson mamrie if we're going to do a
follow-up movie to camp Takota and I can
say that yes maybe the first youtube
video I remember watching ever would
have to be kittens inspired by kittens
love that video the most recent video I
watched was the latest episode of my
drunk kitchen every Thursday on
youtube.com slash our town
the auto-tune Carl Sagan song thing I
don't remember what it's really called
after i was done subscribing to my own
channel i think the first channel i
subscribed to was like jenna Marbles
minute ha
that thing where they do screaming goats
in the middle of songs I don't enjoy it
I find it just like knives to the ears
my favorite youtuber the world doesn't
know about would have to be PewDiePie
he's a foreigner I think and you know
I'm really rooting for him it's a very
very big pond and he's a tiny little
fish would probably have to be Cleopatra
so I could get all the juice on what's
really happening with her and marc
anthony john green and when he runs he
will have my vote you're not even trying
anymore that's offensive and also
hurtful and also may be true